from toronto to las vegas it wasn't just
the juno celebrating music last night
the 2022 billboard awards took over sin
city and brought out all the stars
doji cat goes daring in this custom
schiaparelli structured black gown
complete with gold pasties and she
picked up four glittering trophies
we did it
yeah you did and diddy keeps it cool in
this white double-breasted suit ahead of
his hosting duties
and it's date night for machine gun
kelly and fiance megan fox packing on
the pda as per usual glittering in
diamonds the pair sport matching getups
but check out the manicure on mgk yes
that is thirty thousand dollars worth of
bling on his fingernails but it's his
performance that has everybody on high
alert and this is for our unborn child
hmm could a baby be on the way all right
we hope so later the camera pants to a
very emotional megan who we are wishing
a very happy birthday to the actress
turns 36 today
happy birthday
kylie and travis scott make it a family
affair with four-year-old daughter
stormy tagging along sporting a
one-shoulder white number and some kicks
we are calling her the best dressed of
the night and the billboard awards gave
us quite the moment last night a
surprise appearance by janet jackson
handing out a big honor to her dear
friend this year's billboard music
awards
icon
mary j
blige i think people think
icons are born that way
they become a legend overnight
but that is definitely not the case
it takes a lot of time hard work and a
lot of surviving trial
and error
to achieve greatness